elie wiesel bonsoir bonsoir ça va oui
pour l'instant alors elie wiesel témoin
et survivant de l'holocauste
défenseur infatigable des droits de
l'homme et votre humanisme vous a valu
en 1986 le prix nobel de la paix
c'est un peu l'émission des prix nobel
ici on avait shirin ebadi a quinze jours
donc on fait beaucoup dans le prix nobel
en ce moment extrêmement respectable
alors ali visuel vous êtes né en
roumanie en 1928 à l'âge de 15 ans
s'était déporté à auschwitz puis à
buchenwald à saison vous vous retrouvez
à paris vous n'avez ni famille ni pays
vous est pris en charge par une oeuvre
caritative et vous fait des études de
philosophie à la sorbonne mais vous
hésitez avec le conservatoire à ce
moment là pourquoi avoir choisi la
philosophie
parce que bon j'aurais aimé être chef
d'orchestre parce que quand on chef
d'orchestre il ya quand même une écoute
l'histoire que moi j'avais à dire c'est
pas en russie que je pouvais la d ouais
il fallait des mots ouais donc
le moment de la création de l'état
d'israël vous embarqué à marseille pour
haifa mais en arrivant vous êtes déçus
par le regard que les jeunes israéliens
portent sur les survivants des camps et
vous décidé de revenir à pareil je
n'étais pas prêt c'est une sorte
d'engagement
spirituellement j'étais lié à jérusalem
je suis resté pour y vivre je n'étais
pas prêt je faisais partie je pense je
fais partie de la diaspora juive en
dehors d'israël et mais israël
d'ailleurs déjà un mistral vous revenez
à paris où vous devenez journalistes
mais témoigner de ce que vous avez vécu
devient une véritable obsession et vous
écrivez votre premier livre la nuit un
manuscrit qui au départ m'intéresse pas
beaucoup les éditeurs on se voit le
secret avait été refusée rejetée par
tous les grands éditeurs de paris et
ensuite de new york du monde entier
ouais c'est françois mauriac
qui finalement avait réussir de placer
aux éditions de minuit et voilà c'est
ainsi que ses soeurs clients 58 et
pourquoi ce manuscrit qui est excellent
avait été refusé par tous
il disait premièrement et diviseur de
l'auteur d'un livre là il restera il ne
dira jamais autre chose deuxièmement
smith pas trop triste on n'aime pas les
choses tristes disent-ils puisqu'ils
sont où c'est vrai ils préfèrent autre
chose divertissement c'était pas un
livre pour divertir ouais
j'arrive sur votre expérience dans les
camps
alors ce livre qui le premier de 47
autres l'animatrice américaine oprah
winfrey en a parlé il ya quelques mois
dans son célèbre talk show aux états
unis et 45 ans après sa publication
ce livre est devenu numéro 1 de la liste
des best-sellers du new york times
depuis neuf semaines oui à mon grand
étonnement
mais vous savez moi j'avais cédé tous
les droits aux éditions de minuit dont
je savais pas ce qui se passait avec ce
livre là c'est après que j'avais
découvert que même avant reprend ville
free ce livre avait été vendue en 6
millions d'exemplaires raison de poche 1
mais c'est elle qu'il avance est de
nouveau avec une nouvelle traduction
faite par ma femme et elle a vendu je
pense aux meilleurs et demi en deux mois
mais c'est donc le livre sans lequel je
n'aurais rien d'écrit d'eau c'est
incroyable qu'un livre qui était refusé
par tous les grands éditeurs du monde se
soit vendu depuis à des millions
d'exemplaires et soit de nouveau un
succès dès qu'on en parle la télévision
c'est sans doute quelqu'un qu'on vous
qui peut l'ancien livre je sais pas ça
nous arrive mais en tout cas elle offre
une voiture chaque membre du public erp
a toujours
attiré bien sûr
vous n'aurez en plantant son camping
dans une belle salle
alors vous êtes ici elie wiesel pour
votre dernier livre qui paraît au seuil
qui s'appelle un désir fou de danser
alors c'est l'histoire d'un juif
vieillissant qui souffre d'un excès de
mémoire et qui craint d'avoir basculé
dans la folie et qui va voir une
psychanalyste
alors elle va l'aider en fait à révéler
son douloureux passé familial jusqu'à
retrouver un souvenir enfoui
qui lui permet à lui de comprendre
pourquoi il s'est toujours condamné au
célibat et à la souffrance c'est
quelqu'un qui était fou mais un faux qui
sied qu'il est fou et il faut est-ce que
c'est lui qui est fou ou est ce que
c'est le monde qui est fou et lui qui
est sarr n'en sais rien voilà on aussi
après
en tous les cas elle est quand même à
trouver la clé de son problème une scène
que nous ne raconterons pas évidemment
mais mais quittons fouiller dans son
passé entre sa mère et un homme quoi
seul rom de la thérapeute puisque
chercher de fouiller elle fouille et
elle fouille à trous elle pas tout à
fait parce qu'il ya des secrets en lui
qui restent secrets enfouis dans son
droit sa mémoire et à la fin seulement
il ya ait un dénouement bien sûr
résolution de la symphonie il ya
toujours un fou dans vos romans mais ici
le fou c'est le personnage principal
quoi château un défaut ouais mais elle
mois dort aussi
alors moi j'ai été contact avec eux ils
m'écrivent des lettres et de l'entrée de
la laiterie 3 face à prendre des mois
alors la première lettre g est
intéressante mais trop ça revient deux
fois cinq fois c'est un peu difficile
parce que faire le fou là qu'une
histoire à raconter mais il raconte cinq
fois et là il faut que je réponde cinq
fois
j'avais beaucoup comme ça a beaucoup
comme j'écris sur les faux il pense je
supplie canalis a réussi 4 je ne suis
pas vous êtes juste fou un fou pour les
autres
alors lui pensait tomber sous
l'influencé diabolique d'un dibbouk
ouais alors indiqué que c'est une âme
errante un qui ne peut se sentir en
sécurité que au sein d'une autre âme
quoi oui fait irruption dans cette arène
l'habite il envahit 1,7 à l'envahisseur
qui arrivent et qui prend contrôle qui
prend le pouvoir presque sûr sûr sûr
cette personne donc c'est vrai que donc
mon personnage principal se prend pour
quelqu'un qui est habitée par des
boucles voilà vous avez dit un livre est
un bon livre dans le poids de son
silence ça veut dire quoi ous parce
qu'un livre dépassement fait de mots 1
c'était aussi le silence c'est l'espace
qui partage les mots
et quand il ya beaucoup de silence un
vrai silence dans un silence qui doivent
protester contre l'injustice mais un
silence métaphysique là c'est le poids
du livre qui qui qui qui sont qui s'en
sert et qui sort enrichi
dans tous mes livres c'est comme ça mais
livre commence toujours par avoir de
centaines de pages et je coupe et je
coupe j'ai largué jet lag est toujours
qu'en disant je je je fais tomber
quelques pages elle reste mais invisible
c'est le silence et cépages pires
le cri n'ont poussé le plus fort
justement sur le prix du silence le
silence a incrit le may cry silencieux
très très fort il faut être disant
sensible à ce silence à ce cri
si on crie c'est fini on s'est libéré de
ce crime mais si on le retient en vie
avec
dj sentiment maintenant que je sais tout
mais que je ne comprends rien mais ce
qui est vrai ouais même quand j'écris je
pense avoir expliqué des choses que le
lecteur se débrouille pour comprendre
moi je comprends pas je comprends pas
parce que les choses les questions
essentielles de l'existence veste
question est en vérité il n'ya pas de
répondre pourquoi le mal pourquoi la
cruauté pourquoi la hem surtout on vit
maintenant à une époque où l'a1 domine
le monde entier et c'est une 1/2
fanatiques et de toute mon âme de tout
mon coeur je suis contre le fanatisme où
qu'ils soient et quels qu'ils soient
le vingtième siècle était dominée par le
fanatisme politique à moscou et raciale
à berlin le 21e siècle est déjà dominé
par le fanatisme religieux comme au
moyen âge alors que faut-il faire resté
silencieux non il faut protester bien
sûr
tous les moyens à notre disposition
alors l'oncle du héros est un juif
ultra-orthodoxe donc anti sioniste
puisque les juifs ultra orthodoxes sont
contre l'existence de l'état d'israël
ils disent c'est au messie d'instaurer
l'état juif il faut pas le faire avant
que le messine le fasse et l'état
d'israël est une offense aux seniors une
faute une tragédie alors quand vous
voyez ce qui se passe au moyen-orient
est ce que vous pensez pas que
finalement c'est eux qui ont raison
non non certainement pas maintenant
ils n'ont pas raison parce que je peux
citer d'autres textes contre les leurs
pour prouver que parfois il faut agir
sur le destin et sur l'histoire et
précipitée et donc c'est pas la venue du
messie israël par le messie c'est
simplement un besoin de répondre à une
quête une quête souveraineté
autrefois il y avait quand même une état
souverain royaux en palestine et
le temple a été détruit deux fois peuple
juif a été exilé partout dans le monde
donc le temps d'arriver après surtout
appris à grands traits génie du xxème
siècle de se retrouver souverain sur une
terre ancestrale donc il ya un vieux
peuple avec une nation très jeune dans
les problèmes
qu envoyer le ramasse vous pensez pas
que c'est inextricable situation là bas
oui à la surface oui parce que le
ramasser quoi on dit maintenant pas
d'éclats bilan avec la victoire de
ramasse en mars était une protestation
contre arafat et la corruption de fata
ceux qui sont doutés vrai mais en vérité
le programme de la masse est centrée sur
un point principal la destruction
d'israël donc ceux qui ont voté pour
hamas il faut le dire avec toute la
douleur du monde qu'ils ont voté pour
destruction d'israël
malgré tout je suis optimiste croire que
rama changera tout sinon de contenu et
sharon à la fin un avant sa maladie il y
était moi j'étais convaincu et je
voulais pas les jeux les dangers que
sharon était pour une solution de deux
états il va en paix donc la palestine et
israël vivant côte à côte tous les
autres problèmes pouvaient être résolus
et l'aller les résoudre avec des
sacrifices énormes même il allait les
faire et je pense que son successeur est
haut dans le main par faire la même
chose quand vous apprenez l'existence
d'une bombe islamique en iran est-ce que
vous restez toujours aussi optimiste non
maintenant le danger c'est de laisser
l'iran parce que
le chef
politique religieux de l'iran c'est
réparé mais jen des jeunes des jeunes
est un fou mais pathologiquement malades
foden
et quand il dit qu'il veut une bombe
pour détruire israël il incombe
de le croire
donc que faire alors partout on nous dit
n'est ce pas ça prendra quelques années
de trois ans prison peut-être pour
qu'ils aillent bon mais c'est une bombe
qui va menacer pas seulement israël qui
peut menacer le monde entier ça peu
risqué quand même ça risque de provoquer
une guerre une sorte de conflagration
nucléaire israël restera pas tranquille
s'il monte tel aviv que pensez vous
qu'israël ferait il s'appelle li
posterai c'est plus facile d'arrêter
hitler en 39 que le président iranien
aujourd'hui parce que il n'y avait pas
deux milliards de personnes derrière lui
alors qu'aujourd'hui ce serait le cas
exactement 1 exactement sittler
maintenant le sépare le document n'est
ce pas les archives on aurait pu arrêter
hitler parce que même les l'état major a
espéré des sports qui se serait arrêté
et bien aujourd'hui avec l'iran ce pas
si simple
israël avait détruit le pôle réacteurs
nucléaires de l'irak c'est plus facile
aux hijas de plus facile il y avait une
année qu'un seul réacteur est visible il
rend à 14,14 souterrain dans des centres
urbains donc attaqué sur ses actes là
qui sait combien de vies
ça coûterait est-ce que vous pensez que
l'homme évolue ou qu'il est toujours
aussi barbare qui est des millénaires je
vous dirai ce qui me fait espérer quand
même
il ya
50 60 70 euros autant de l'horreur
il y avait très peu de comités
internationaux pour les droits de
l'homme ouais aujourd'hui à près de 1500
c est partout m'achever et moi je me
rends parts habitude ne s'est pas au aux
endroits où ça se passe je trouve
toujours des jeunes qui sont passionnés
tous les droits de l'homme qui quittent
leur bureau qui quittent leurs parents
qu'ils quittent leur vie quoi pour aller
travailler pour les victimes et ses
nobles et c'est cette mission noble
assumer pas les jeunes et bah je vis
dans un monde jeune je suis enseignant -
je peux vous dire que ça pour moi en
tout cas c'est une raison d'espérer
la river à pétra en jordanie la
conférence des prix nobel sur la
sécurité le développement du monde vous
avez y participer c'est important c'est
utile 13 pourtant on a fait des gens une
fois ça vient après en 1988 j'avais fait
avec mitterrand oui moi je m'en souviens
quand j'étais vraiment mal
et c'est un grand rôle à l'époque nous
étions encore à miss beauté noire et
boit du café avant vous découvriez qu'il
était ami bousquet aussi exactement
avant et alors le roi jordanien pas un
ami commun ok moi de te demander si je
vais faire à une chose avec lui dans la
fpt et donc l'année dernière en juin
mais fin mai nous avions déjà une
conférence le titre était face un
montant danger on avait 30 30 prix nobel
quelques chefs d'état et pendant trois
jours c'était une grande discussion une
bonne discussion sur l'état du monde
maintenant on va leur faire de nouveau
le 20 21 22 juin toujours à petra avec
le roi et moi même temps moi j'y crois
quand vous avez un prix nobel un groupe
ii prix nobel il ya une écoute pour des
raisons que j'ignore pourquoi le prix
nobel à ce prestige personne ne le sait
mais il ya ce prestige parce que nous
présente nous représentons vraiment une
autorité morale une grande autorisation
autorités que nous ayons et l'avenir
aussi peut-être qu'à l'avenir avec le
monde soit dirigé par un conseil des
sages que ça veut dire c'est exactement
la question laurent on it up brancher
tous les deux là on est on est un peu
logique et on a un peu d'espoir encore
et on espère beaucoup dans les gens
comme vous quoi pensez pas que ce serait
bien si le monde était dirigée par un
conseil des sages comme dans les livres
de science fiction ces deux prix lambert
dirige le manceau serait pas pire
[Musique]
aux éditions du seuil mais la baisse
mais
avant de quitter je vais vous faire une
petite interview elie j'ai un truc à
vous dire d'accord tall et cie
interviewé lit j'ai un truc à vous dire
et
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé que votre
mère vous dise
à l'appel directement
ce que j'aurais aimé en fait je me dise
qu
elle vivrait longtemps pour me voir
grande et
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé que votre
père vous disent
qu'ils étaient fiers de moi qu'est ce
que vous auriez aimé que françois
mauriac vous disent
que j'ai justifié l'espoir qu'ils
avaient en moi qu'est ce que vous auriez
aimé que votre rabat vous disent oh que
je suis bon élève
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé que dieu
vous dise 10dans qu'est ce que tu as
fait là bas
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé que le
diable vous dise toi aussi
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé qu'un
asie vous disent rien qu'est ce que vous
auriez aimé que françois mitterrand vous
dise pourquoi elle était l'amie de
bousquet
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé que
george bush vous dise
j'arrête la guerre qu'est ce que vous
auriez aimé qu'un palestinien vous
disent vivre en paix qu'est ce que vous
auriez aimé que l'histoire vous disent
que ce n'est pas très
qu'est ce que vous auriez aimé que je
vous dise
que je reviens quand vous vous référez
jelle un désir fou de danse et vous sur
les seuls à mes yeux
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu